Tick Tock bills itself as the last Sunny
corner of the internet but many people
see a dark side
beneath the app's surface lies
incredibly Advanced artificial
intelligence that has learned what
people like with stunning impact
Tick Tock signed up a billion users in
half the time it took Facebook
the West has always accused China of
copying technological advances but now
Silicon Valley is rushing to mimic the
Chinese app in response to tick tock's
short videos YouTube introduced shorts
and Instagram released reels unlike
Instagram where your feed consists of
photos and videos from people you follow
Tick Tock relies on a strategy of
recommendations first you find yourself
watching videos from people you never
chose to watch who you don't follow it's
what Tick Tock believes will most appeal
to you imagine the effect of binging on
an endless stream of 15 or 30 second
videos for an hour and a half a day the
average amount of time users spend on
tick tock that dopamine Rush is
addictive and a study from the Technical
University of Denmark found that the
constant stream of information from
social media can shorten our attention
span over time and that this effect
occurs not only on social media but also
across diverse domains including books
web searches movie popularity and More
in other words a shorter attention span
impacts every aspect of your life when
was the last time you sat through an
entire movie at home can you even bear
to watch older movies that are slower
paced no Mr mother check it's not for us
or Worse what happens if our society is
filled with people who lack the focus to
think things through or complete
projects that take a lot of time
in the way that TV news in the 70s
shortened reports to one minute 30
seconds to keep the attention of the
television audience
Tick Tock is now shortening our
attention span from minutes to seconds
anything longer isn't worth our time
unless we're really really interested in
the subject matter does a 30-minute
YouTube video now feel like an
unbearably long documentary
our addiction to the screen is literally
damaging our brains multiple Studies
have shown that those addicted to gaming
and the internet have a reduced volume
of gray matter in their brain
gray matter has a large number of
neurons present which allows it to
process information in the brain so
spending too much time on your phone is
literally causing your brain tissue to
atrophy
much of the damage occurs in the frontal
lobe the area that largely determines
success in life be it academics career
or relationships then there is the issue
of the quality of the videos you're
watching there's been a lot of talk
lately that Tick Tock in the U.S is
different from the version shown in
China where Tick Tock is known as doe
ying a user wrote on quora that is Tick
Tock feed is filled with teenagers doing
stupid things whereas his doying feed is
filled with self-improvement photography
travel calligraphy life hacks trivia
interesting new products and of course
cute dog cat videos by the way in China
those aged 14 and under are limited to
using delgi for 40 minutes a day and are
blocked from using it between 10 pm to 6
A.M the differences between the two tick
tocks is Stark as social media expert
Tristan Harris told 60 Minutes they make
their domestic version a spinach version
of tick tock while they've shipped the
Opium version to the rest of the World
perhaps that speaks to the difference in
career aspirations of Chinese and
American children in China most kids
dream of becoming an astronaut in
America most kids aspire to be social
media influencers
toward the end of Donald Trump's
presidency he tried and failed to ban
Tick Tock in the U.S or Force the
Beijing company that owns it fight dance
to sell tick tock's American arm to a
domestic owner the most frequent
criticism of tick-tock is privacy issues
China can demand whatever information it
likes from companies based in its
country a damning report from BuzzFeed
in June 2022 claimed U.S user data was
repeatedly accessed from Tick Tock staff
in China
Tick Tock has always insisted that
information from the U.S is stored in
the U.S which right now is on the
servers of American company Oracle and
at a recent New York Times event its CEO
denied handing over Americans data to
China no U.S no foreign government has
asked us for U.S user Data before really
to heaven and if they did we would say
no but Washington isn't buying it in
December lawmakers in the House and
Senate introduced legislation that could
ban Tick-Tock in the U.S after the FBI
warned it could be used by China for
spite the Senate has voted to ban
Tick-Tock from all government-issued
phones as of this video it still has to
pass the house before going to President
Biden for approval Tick-Tock is growing
exponentially it was the most downloaded
app in 2021 and remains on top in 2022
although it may have started off as a
dancing app it is increasingly becoming
a news source for Gen Z injection calls
for hearsay like during Johnny Depp's
defamation trial against his ex-wife
Amber Heard my dog stepped on a bee
newsthink does have a tick tock account
where I hope to educate and Enlighten
people in a short span of time but it's
exactly that short span of time that's
problematic
we constantly crave more and more
information in less and less time and
that may one day spell disaster
Tick Tock is slowly becoming a news
source there's a lot of news these days
about climate change one company is
trying to tackle it simply and
effectively Ren is a website and app
that makes it easy for you to calculate
your carbon footprint by answering a few
questions about your lifestyle you can
discover your carbon footprint and how
to reduce it you can make a monthly
contribution this will go toward
projects like providing clean cooking
fuel to refugees in Uganda you'll
receive monthly updates on the projects
you support since Ren launched in 2019
they've sent over a million dollars in
funding to projects planting trees
protecting rainforests and otherwise
fighting the climate crisis you can
offset your carbon footprint today on
rent by signing up with a custom link in
my description the first 100 people who
sign up with my link will have 10 extra
trees planted in their name thanks for
watching for news think I'm Cindy Palm
[Music]